vincent vous êtes magiciens vous êtes un
ami de pierre jean salençon oui vous
êtes passés au crible sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque vous avez participé à
cette fameuse soirée
décrite comme un dîner camps distincts
le premier round j'ai vu des vidéos de
vous faisant des tours de magie juste
vincent ya plein de gens qui ont dit
mais pourquoi ils ont mis ces vidéos sur
les réseaux sociaux
or voilà la question est pourquoi
braillements expliqué en deux mots je
suis vincent auto entrepreneur depuis
2010 9 d'accord sans avoir jamais rien
fait de mal à personne je me retrouve là
voilà et c'est toi comment vous
retrouvez la soirée alors je suis ami de
monsieur chalencon ils m'ont fait venir
souvent chez lui en tête à tête d'accor
voilà pour parler projets voilà j'en
suis dans la toute légalité d'être chez
lui d'accord une musette et station j'ai
tout voilà je peux pour émettre des
tours de magie pour les invités alors je
viens pour distribuer ma carte de visite
et pour faire ma publicité
alors on vous a vu faire un tour de
magie par exemple à des personnalités
sur les réseaux sociaux tout ça oui vous
vous êtes je suis collectionneur de
photos de vedettes
on peut dire ça comme ça d'accord je
fais ça depuis longtemps et j'ai
retrouvé des photos qui datent voilà
toutes ces photos la halle sont elles ne
sont pas de 2020 non ou tout début 2020
peut-être jusqu'à mars grand maximum
mars de nous était la soirée les gens
font alors soir et bien sûr le chaland
son bail à quai ou genton pas moi mais
non monsieur monsieur challenges sont
jamais laissés sur place
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur chalencon monsieur chalencon ne
me prévient de doc une soirée il me fait
venir chez lui le [ __ ] des soupes les
dents mais c'est important donc là au
départ et vous dis pas qu'elles soir il
vous fait venir chez lui là il me fait
aka passé à 22 heures si tu veux il ya
deux trois personnes si tu veux donner
ton contact tu viens tu donnes ton
contact d'un mois je n'ai pas vus comme
des gens affirment 50 62 cents personnes
non non non moi j'ai vu grand maximum
dix personnes en bas de l'immeuble
mais je ne peux pas témoigner qu'elle
était là au d'accord pour moi je suis en
bas de l'immeuble à sont dans la rue
tout le monde a droit d'être dans la rue
voilà bon ça c'est un fait qu'on a plein
d'infos différents donc pour vous il y
avait combien de personnes à cette
soirée mais moi pour moi ce que vous
êtes arrivé à 8h je suis arrivé à 22
heures je ne sais pas s'il ya eu une
soirée
moi j'ai vu grand maximum une dizaine de
personnes je ne peux pas dire qu'il y
avait autant de monde
il y avait des tables dressées avec des
moyens dignes à monsieur challans on m'a
mis dans une pierre et des restes de
près d'un an n'avait pas de restes de
repas de quoi que ce soit moi j'ai
simplement fait avec la grotte n'ont ni
drogue ni repas ni quoi que ce soit moi
j'en prends juste venu pour pour donner
mon comptable je suis une personne sans
histoire voilà et je poste souvent les
fruits comme ça vous avez posé lycée
vous avez posté une vidéo
quand j'ai posté une vidéo oui c'est
celle de monsieur mizrahi we win paris
j'étais uniquement avec monsieur mezrahi
on ne m'a pas présenté de monde on ne
m'a pas présenter quoi que ce soit je
suis las d'attendre à de faire le
guignol avec ma caméra et monsieur
chalencon voilà je fais ça et donc là et
personne d'autre je n'ai vu personne
d'autre
moi je suis venu pour faire ma promotion
voilà auprès de ce monsieur je ne viens
pas pour faire du der pas de je ne sais
quoi est ce que c'est vrai que vous avez
reçu des menaces
j'ai reçu des menaces oui de quoi de qui
et d'anonymes de plein de monde on vous
disait quoi
ahmed était fini ou ou temaru on
retrouvera ou ceci cela c'est un moment
donné il faut arrêter moi moi je je suis
juste amis de monsieur chalencon voilà
comme ici présents je viens pour pour
montrer ce gentil monsieur ce que je
fais et il n'y a rien d'autre il n'y a
pas de sous-entendus de je-ne-sais-quoi
je vois la cccc c'est alors une photo
photo également qui est sorti avec eric
dupond-moretti bien sûr
je suis ce qui a été sortie de son
contexte qui n'était pas du tout à la
soirée parce qu'à un moment aussi on en
est aujourd'hui
eric dupond moretti était la soirée mais
c'est une autre une photo qui était pas
ce n'est pas une soirée tout court il
n'a jamais été au palais vivienne ça
c'est avenue de breteuil devant les
studios de média one de 7 à vous
d'accord très là et cette photo date du
22 octobre 2019 a été invité à la 18h08
54 secondes je viens et essaie de
vérifier ce matin d'accord alors en
avoir eu juste la question que tout le
monde se pose c'est est ce qu'il y avait
un membre du gouvernement à cette soirée
non non j alors monsieur mezrahi
d'accord ici avec moi monsieur leroy est
juste voilà monsieur charles venu il ya
un autre monsieur mais je ne connais pas
ce monsieur n'à mais c'est pas un membre
du gouvernement de quoi que ce soit mais
je miserais il n'a jamais été l'ombre du
gouvernement un rôle à doha elle voit là
et voilà d'après beaucoup critiquent ils
étaient très contents de me rencontrer
en aucun cas je n'ai vu du membre du
gouvernement
quand je suis en congé ou d'école quand
le serveur qui est venu hier et dit
qu'avec 40 personnes peut-être que vous
êtes arrivé à la fin de la alors ils
vont aussi
avant je suis arrivé à la fin à corbas
blement d'un événement de condy quai
existant mais moi on ne m'a pas convié
c'était à 7,7 ce je dirais sors pas si
vous voulez appeler ça comme ça je n'ai
pas participé à ça je suis venu pour
donner mon contact en tout bien tout
honneur ça s'arrête là voilà les
événements ont pâli vivienne bien avant
mars 2020 c'est là que j'ai commencé à
rencontrer monsieur chalencon voilà mais
je n'ai pas fait de soirée là bas
d'accord mais pardon monsieur on a vu
une photo avec monsieur mizrahi ce we
donc ça s'était fait quand cette photo
là or cette vidéo ça fait la vidéo et ce
soir là elles sont là même de son
gagnant même du monde
enfin non mais il me semble t'il des
tables ya il ya une tape derrière moi
d'accord non câble de trois personnes
d'accord voilà c'est il ya quelqu'un de
beau aussi ayant besoin de moi mais j'ai
comme voilà mais en tout cas la personne
qui est venu ici le soi-disant serveurs
je n'ai rien contre lui je n'ai rien
contre personne moi pour côtoyer père
jean chalencon je n'ai jamais vu ce
monsieur
voilà je ne sais pas qui il est je ne
connais pas voilà d'accord et je cherche
à me faire connaître donc c'est pour ça
que je rencontre des gens de cette
envergure vous êtes vous êtes dans quel
état aujourd'hui parce que sa défaire le
monde
c'est un déferlement voilà moi moi moi
je suis moi c'est simple comme je n'ai
rien à me reprocher je vais partout et
je raconte
les chais je n'ai rien à me reprocher je
n'ai rien fait je suis un sens une
personne sans histoire là je vis chez
mes parents il n'y a pas de mal à ça et
voilà je viens donner à ma carte de
visite pour pont pour me faire connaître
monsieur chalencon comme je suis à table
avec lui assez souvent et juste avec lui
je précise
voilà c'est pour moi c'est un tremplin
médiatique puis commence à la vie d'hier